[Music]
there's a lot of controversy over the
origins of the coronavirus that sparked
the pandemic questions over where the
virus came from have fueled another
debate over a kind of research where
scientists tweak the genetic information
of a virus or other pathogen to give it
new properties it's called gain of
function and this isn't the first time
it's come under scrutiny it's used in
research years ago made way for two of
the most controversial studies in modern
science see those titles they don't look
all that concerning but some thought
that details were
for those experiments scientists
modified a potentially deadly virus and
supercharged it virologists were testing
how a type of bird flu which can be
deadly to humans but doesn't transmit
well among people would need to change
genetically to have Pandemic potential
in the 2000s the flu strain involved in
those studies that caused major health
problems globally but still it wasn't as
contagious as some Public Health experts
thought a major pandemic causing virus
could be for the studies the scientists
altered the virus's genetic information
in very specific ways that would help
the pathogens spread among ferrets more
easily ferrets are often used as
standards for humans because they're
susceptible to some of the same viruses
in one study the unmodified version of
the virus didn't spread through the air
among ferrets but the genetically
modified flu had a new capability
Airborne transmission
that's a key ingredient of a pandemic
virus that new ability is what gain of
function refers to the virus gains
capabilities it didn't have before when
reports became public that researchers
had been successful in modifying an
already deadly virus to make it even
more worrisome many fear that gain of
function research gone wrong could
unleash a global pandemic rules were put
in place to better police the research
there was even a moratorium on this kind
of work but that didn't last so what
does all that have to do with this
pandemic this year questions over the
origins of the covet virus went from
Fringe to mainstream people wanted to
know did it accidentally leak from a lab
or did it spill over from nature because
of human animal contact that question is
still under investigation but that
uncertainty is part of what strong
attention back to gain a function there
is some debate about whether some of the
work that research labs in Wuhan were
doing was in fact gain of function
Johannes were the first coveted cases
were recorded so people wondered whether
handling of viruses by Labs there could
have accidentally led to a leak that
sparked the first covet outbreaks the
labs have repeatedly said that's not the
case my co-worker Amy Dr Marcus is one
of the reporters on our health and
science team who has been covering the
origin story and more recently gain of
function research I called her up to ask
her why the gain of function debate felt
so urgent again
when we've looked at this question
before we've talked about the potential
for causing a pandemic in a kind of
almost hypothetical way now we're living
through a pandemic it's very real now in
a way that it wasn't during the previous
rounds of debate and I think that's one
reason why the debate over gain a
function feels so sharp and so immediate
so the research is so controversial why
do researchers do it Amy had some
answers for us there are many scientists
who ardently and convincingly
argue that it's very important to
understand what a pathogen might do next
one of the scientists said to me it's
like knowing your enemy you want to know
how to fight against what happens in the
future and some infectious disease
researchers argue that the only way to
do that is to make genetic tweaks that
help them understand what turns the
virus from run-of-the-mill to pandemic
causing they also say that work helps
with testing drugs and vaccines gain of
function research can involve microbes
or other pathogens that don't initially
pose pandemic threats to us a lot of
work that's done in the gain of function
field involves not human pathogens but
bat viruses but
these can make genetic changes that may
eventually turn into diseases that
affect humans the emergence of a new
dangerous virus that's what scares
people and it's why some gain of
function research especially the kind
that involves risky pathogens is under
the microscope again but gain of
function extends Beyond infectious
disease to other fields there it's not
really as controversial because it
doesn't carry the same public health
risks gain of function research is the
Workhorse of Modern Biology so it's
unlikely it'll go away altogether Amy
told me that researchers are already
doing gain of function work on the
covet-causing virus so we can be better
prepared to tweak our vaccines as new
variants arise
so where do we go from here that gets us
back to where we started the origins
question we still don't know where the
virus came from and we may never know
definitively but getting answers could
help us figure out where to draw the
line on the riskiest of gain of function
research whether contentious or not
science affects our lives every day so
it's important we're all involved in
deciding how it's done
if you have any questions about gain of
function research or the pandemic in
general please leave them in the
comments and don't forget to hit
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
updates gracias